hola
para que es la ciencia
después de lo que habló juan diego y que
hizo un recuento de algunos de los
avances que como humanidad hemos
alcanzado en el desarrollo de la ciencia
y la tecnología y además por nuestra
experiencia puesto que en estos tiempos
que corren la ciencia y sus aplicaciones
están muy a la mando de nosotros
en pocos años nos hemos como humanidad
vistos inmersos en todas las bondades y
algunas dificultades también que ha
traído la ciencia sin ella pues no ahora
como entendemos nuestra vida
prácticamente sería muy demasiado
diferente no tendríamos celulares no
podríamos viajar a muchos sitios no
sabríamos de todos los avances médicos
no podríamos entender muchos mecanismos
de nuestro propio organismo y de los
fenómenos que nos suceden a nuestro
alrededor por eso es que pensamos cuando
hablamos de ciencia en todo el bien que
nos ha traído
pero si solamente
pensamos en el término me gustaría que
retomáramos si solamente la ciencia es
importante por sus aplicaciones
cuando yo yo he tenido la oportunidad de
dedicarme a la química
y me apasionó desde pequeña no ponía
cara de circunstancia cuando voy a
empezar la clase todo lo contrario me
parecía como magia poder transformar las
sustancias poder darle otras propiedades
unas
líquidos sólidos y transformarlos y eso
me parecía que era fascinante
gracias al apoyo de mi familia de mis
maestros pude dedicarme y profundizar
más en la química tanto en el colegio
como en la universidad
cuando yo digo química y que me he
dedicado a ella pensarán que me la paso
rodeada en un laboratorio bata blanca
con trajes tubos de ensayo
con líquidos de diferentes colores
algunos con burbujitas en realidad no es
decir soy química computacional y
cálculo en computadoras datos sobre las
sustancias obtengo números y por medio
de programas con estos números luego
se grafican y se ven como se pueden ver
en la pantalla
de ellos de estos resultados yo infiero
como
cómo y por qué están sucediendo estas
reacciones o por qué estos materiales
tienen estas propiedades
cuando pude
trabajaron muy poco porque fue muy poco
en la industria
me parecía rutinario y que todos los
días hacíamos lo mismo cuando conocí la
investigación en especial en la química
computacional
era un trabajo creativo podían
teniendo el área flexible
y además se me preguntaban por mis ideas
ya que no nos gusta que nos pregunten
sobre lo que pensamos sobre los
resultados que estamos obteniendo al
principio es desafiante da susto pero
luego cuando uno ve que pueden que
confían las personas en la inteligencia
en la creatividad en la sensibilidad de
uno se siente bien y me parecía que era
motivante este trabajo y tuve la fortuna
la gracia de poder dedicarme a la
investigación
en esta área
no sólo eso dedicándome a ello
viví pude vivir mucho tiempo en europa
en barcelona es una ciudad preciosa
he conocido durante este tiempo a gente
maravillosa de varios países con una
calidad humana
que me ha alimentado que me ha
fortalecido que seguramente me ha hecho
también mejor persona también puede
conocer ciudades roma londres parís
madrid
tenía 21
6 27 años
si a veces miraba mi vida hacia atrás
estaba
es mucho
la vida me ha dado mucho más de lo que
esperaba ha superado con creces mis
expectativas
es fabuloso estoy viviendo una vida
maravillosa
una pregunta
surgió en mi interior
primero muy tenue
pero con el tiempo se fue haciendo más
insistente
hasta el momento de ser angustiante
realmente vale la pena estos números
realmente vale la pena dedicar 50 o más
horas semanales con la computadora
obteniendo datos leyendo aprendiendo
qué significado tiene para la humanidad
vale la pena
no convivir con mis padres con mi
hermano
salir de mi entorno cultural social
familiar
tiene sentido lo que estoy haciendo
no era continuamente viviría deprimida
si fuese así
se la pasaba muy bien
pero esta pregunta
esta pregunta estaba allí y necesitaba
responderla
en estos en ese tiempo
cuando si a los misioneros identes
era gente buena
gente muy generosa
y abrieron la puerta de su casa me
encantaba pasar el tiempo con ellos
y hablaban de sus misiones en áfrica en
bolivia en ecuador
yo pensaba
vale la pena su vida
están transformando
todo todo su entorno
y le hablaban del evangelio
pero sobre todo
yo notaba que lo vivían que se
esforzaban por vivirlo
así que
un día me dijo una de ellas
dios es conocimiento
dios es la verdad
sin darme cuenta esa frase recordarme
esa frase porque esa frase yo la había
leído
pero una cosa era la iglesia y otra el
trabajo otra la vida otra de las calles
otra de las convivencias y las fiestas
pero ese día fue diferente en ese
momento fue diferente hubo un clic
todo tiene sentido
distinguir que mi vida
que todo ese camino en el que yo había
transitado
buscando
algo era que estaba buscando la verdad
que me fascinaba la ciencia porque es un
camino muy honesto para encontrar la
verdad
la ciencia solo un medio no un fin
todos los esfuerzos que hacemos por
encontrar la verdad
contribuyen a la humanidad
tenía sentido cada número que yo obtenía
porque ese número me permitía conocer
más la verdad
soy misionera y dente
y misiones de aquí en loja en la utpl
donde desarrolló mi investigación
mi vida tiene un sentido
porque quiero conocer más de la verdad y
quiero acompañar a otros a que también
la conozcan
yo creo que cada uno de nosotros
tengamos su verdad
yo creo que existe la verdad
y que cada uno de nosotros de forma muy
particular insustituible y que nadie más
puede acceder a un fragmento así sea muy
muy pequeño de la verdad y eso suma
todo lo que hagamos en donde ustedes se
desarrollen
en dónde
en cualquier campo en cualquier
disciplina donde estudien o trabajen
ustedes
pueden acercarse a la verdad ya que nos
gusta la verdad
no nos gusta que nos mientan no nos
gusten las medias verdades
ni las casi verdades que son casi
mentiras
nos gusta la transparencia
porque hemos sido configurados por la
verdad
porque anhelamos como seres humanos la
verdad porque la verdad nos hace libres
la verdad nos hace encontrar una vida
plena yo les invito a que descubran con
todo su esfuerzo en el sitio donde estén
con las personas que les rodean en el
entorno en el que viven en el momento de
su vida en el que están
vivan
buscando la verdad que está en ustedes y
que está en su entorno en donde quiera
que sea con las otras personas con las
que conviven
busquen luchen esfuércense vale la pena
porque entonces estamos conociendo la
verdad todo lo que yo aporte aporta para
que como humanidad como familia como
hijos de un mismo padre
podamos conocer
la verdad
disfrutar de la libertad disfrutar de la
comunión de estar todos juntos luchando
y esforzándonos para transformar nuestra
realidad porque la verdad transforma no
solo por dentro también a nuestro
alrededor
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]